I'm the general producer of Hyrule
warriors coin Ummah of Kuwait ECMO I'm
the development producer of Hyrule
warriors Hayashi of Kuwait ECMO I'm a
NUMA of Nintendo supervisor there are a
lot of us in the Hyrule warriors
development team who grew up playing The
Legend of Zelda so getting the chance to
work on this series we were actually a
little nervous but a NUMA son told us we
could do whatever we like a number of
times and it became the action style
that it is now
a big difference between this and the
Zelda games is that you're fighting an
army and there are multiple battles
occurring on the field at once if your
forces are in trouble you'll get a
warning so you have the option to go out
there and help out your allies what I
think is great with the Zelda world is
how giant bosses appear and you have to
think about how to beat them I think
those things are what makes the essence
of Zelda which I think will be a new
discovery for fans of the dynasty
Warriors series there's also a
two-player mode you can play 2 players
by using both TV and gamepad it's not a
split screen experience so you're able
to each be fully immersed on a single
screen there are a lot of playable
characters but you know since it's the
legend of zelda there are linked and
Princess Zelda empa who appears through
the series is playable as well also
midna from Twilight Princess makes an
appearance as a playable character if
there is a certain character you like in
the series this is the first game where
you'll be able to play as your favorite
character there are a lot of playable
characters in the dynasty warrior series
but man the ideas they come up with for
what kind of moves they give the
characters are amazing they really think
of amazing things
so now it's really turning out as a
great new Zelda collaboration title
that's worthy of the name Hyrule
warriors since this collaboration was a
first of its kind we were able to make
it a great game it's like a celebration
of both franchises I really hope you all
look forward to it as a collaborative
title it has both the essence of Zelda
and the essence of dynasty warriors as
well as a lot of other essences they
have all mixed in to form a brand new
experience it'll be great if both fans
get interested in playing the other
series it'll make me really happy if
they all have fun playing